good afternoon and welcome i'm vishakha
desai special advisor to president
Bollinger and a professor of practice
and more importantly for this afternoon
occasion member of the committee on
global thought on behalf of my
colleagues it's my great pleasure to
welcome all of you to the second annual
global thought lecture which is also a
world leaders forum program Committee on
global thought and the world leaders
forum are both special initiatives of
president Bollinger to enhance expand
and strengthen the global dimension of
this great University in one of the most
global cities of the world Committee on
global thought made up of an
interdisciplinary group of senior
scholars from around the campus is
designed to develop new analytic
concepts and create new forms of
knowledge relevant for the
interconnected globalizing world that we
live in through a collaborative
intellectual process members of the
committee are committed to facilitating
the emergence of new concepts
methodologies and fields of inquiry in
the pursuit of global knowledge given
the Mandate of this committee you see
why we are so pleased to be able to
bring mr. Pascal Lamy to this campus a
true global thinker himself in addition
to giving this talk mr. Lamie is also
spent with our time with our
undergraduate students and I must say he
is very generously given a whole day to
really be with a number of different
groups on campus this particular program
of engaging our world leaders with
undergraduates is part of an inaugural
program that president Bollinger
initiated to create special learning
opportunities for undergraduates so that
the world leaders who come to campus
actually engage in a deeper conversation
with undergraduate students so our very
special thanks go to mr. Lamie for being
so Jen
with his time I also want to thank the
undergraduate committee of CTE for
developing an excellent program in
conjunction with this lecture which
included a seminar with Professor whose
their component ownio and a dynamic
session with mr. Lamie himself this
morning we hope to add such valuable
learning components to other world
leaders for a in the fall so do stay
tuned and get involved with all of us
now it's my great pleasure to turn the
microphone over to President Lee
Bollinger a visionary leader a great
partner I'm privileged to be working
with him and someone who is committed to
making Columbia a truly global
University in content strategy and
practice ladies and gentlemen please
welcome President Lee Bollinger
thank you very much for Shaka so let me
just say a few things and to introduce
this and then invite Pascal Lamy to
deliver the talk now first of all the
Shaka Shaka has many roles here and
she's on the Committee on global thought
she's a special adviser to me she's
teaching of course she's helping us in
all kinds of ways become more global in
the way we think as former head of the
Asia Society there's nobody better
qualified to bring this perspective to
us so we're very grateful and the thing
that she has done here with the world
leaders forum really through the first
time we have taken the the gift of
having someone of Pascale amis knowledge
and eloquence here and integrated and
begun to integrate it into the
educational experience for our students
so hence the meetings that happened
beforehand with students to prepare for
this lecture we want to do more and more
of that I want to thank Jose Ocampo
who's a professor at SEPA and a very
distinguished faculty member for being
part of this he's also on the committee
on global thought and Richard Parker
who's a professor in the mailman School
of Public Health and will give a
response to Pascal Lamy the Committee on
global thought is again one of the
things we created really I think in 2006
or so and the idea was what is global
thought and our people thinking about
this whole new phenomena of
globalization very theoretical sort of
enterprise but that's what we do in a
university we we think about ideas and
we think about theories so it's really
been a great addition to the University
and it's a partner in this in this
lecture today it's the second annual
Committee on global thought lecture so
that's very important
Pascal Lamia has been a figure in in the
world of globalization in my view
there's nothing more important in
today's world than the driving forces of
trade foreign investment the ways in
which the opening of markets all over
the world in the past 2025 years in the
last generation the ways in which the
economic activity of trade in good and
services and investments has transformed
the way we live this along with the
other major new invention of the
internet and communications technologies
are profoundly affecting everything that
we know from the past so this is the
world and this is the world that is
ahead of our students this is the world
we have to introduce them to there are
all kinds of issues problems vastly
important things that have to be solved
and there's incredible potential in this
if it's done right
Pascal Lamy was the head of the WTO
until very recently again an
organization an international
organization dedicated trying to work in
a multilateral way in organizing this
trade there's no place in the world
better situated to understand what's
going on than that and he was a very
great and effective leader there's a
Marten school at Oxford it's just been
created it's a quite unusual institution
and we have something here that we're
creating the Michael Doyle is heading
called the global Policy Institute or
something along that line the idea is to
bring together people who are academics
doing research doing the things we do
very well and marry that more
effectively with institutions and
organizations and people who are
actually trying to implement things so
how do you do that it sounds like it's
something
that should be fairly normal and
comfortable but it's actually not and
the Martin school was given a very big
gift of a hundred and fifty million
dollars and then is added to that and it
is devoted to bringing people together
with in Oxford to work on great problems
of the 21st century we think that's
terrific we may want to work with the
Martin school we may want to work with
we will want to work with Pascal Lamy we
are interested in how you do this not
only within Colombia but more broadly
with partners around the world produce
this report as one of its opening acts
now for the long term it's a terrific
report I mean I you know many many
reports are reports they are filed away
and you never see them again this is one
that actually lays out an understanding
of the world a sense of trying to really
make sense of it
and then some recommendations that are
actually quite powerful and I know that
Pascal Lamy is dedicated as in the chair
of the Commission that produced that
report to trying to move to try to move
that forward and that's what he's here
today to talk about we're very grateful
Pascal for your presence here ask Allah
me
well good afternoon let me thank you
president
brenger for this invitation which I
think was born in a Swiss ski station
where we usually go not to ski and if if
a friendly place is a place where you
have many friends then I think Columbia
University is a friendly place to me a
number of you sitting on this front row
but also in the faculty I've had the
occasion to work with for many years now
and thank you for what you just said
including on this Oxford Martin Report
which I will mention from time to time
in these few remarks before we enter
into a more interactive discussions
which of course I will devote to some
consideration on global governance an
issue which I've been experiencing for
many years now if I look at my
professional life I spent roughly 15
years in national governance which I'll
call the solid state of governance I
then spent 15 years of my life in
European governance which I called the
liquid state of governance and I then
spent roughly 10 years in international
governance which I call the gazers state
of governance so I've been travelling
through various levels of governance but
I've also been trying to think a bit
about what I was doing
including in a few books or publications
the last of these you just mentioned
president which was this Oxford Martin
school report which I had the privilege
to chair conduct if not draft lie by
line at least direct with a fantastic
group of people and which led I think to
pretty innovative suggestions on how the
challenges we have with global
governance could be addressed in order
to cope more effectively than what we've
done so far in addressing challenges for
future generations whether they're our
environment whether they are
geopolitical whether there are about
diseases where they're about social
inequality ISM and that's the latest on
the on the shelf
now I'll start with pretty obvious
configuration that globalization is the
real great transformation about time so
not that waves globalization haven't
happened previously in history but this
one is clearly without any precedent
whether its size or whether it's its
speed it has a parent allottee with
previous phases of globalization which
is that it's moved by technology as
previous phases of globalization in
human history what triggered the present
phase is a revolution in shrinking
crushing distance all the cost of
distance thus facilitating circulation
of goods people services ideas
informations we also know and I think it
doesn't need a long discussion that this
racialism challenges on how to live
together in this new phase of
globalization which is the root question
of the governance of human systems what
we also know is that we have to cope
with an inherent tension between the
global nature of many issues humanity
needs to grab with in order for some to
survive for others to make the world a
better place so we know that a larger
and larger part of these issues are
global but we also know that by nature
governance is local why is governance
local by nature because politics are
about managing human community and that
power needs to be legitimized it needs
to be legitimate people need to accept
together that they have a political
system that manages a number of issues
and this necessarily connects governance
with proximity with the notion by the
people who accept to system of
governance that this is necessary for
togetherness for belonging in many ways
it has to do with community hands by the
way this philosophical tradition of
subsidiarity which has been there for
many many
is now in the way you interpret the
relationship of people to power this
tension is by many people who've been
writing or thinking about global
governance this tension between the
global nature of the problem and the
local nature of governance is a problem
for most thinkers in global governance
not for me I believe that this tension
is inherent and that the fact that
legitimacy has to do with proximity is a
fundamental principle of political
philosophy I'm glad that we have this
problem now having said that it's a
problem we have to live with and that we
will not overcome these tensions in
globalizing governance the way we've
localized governance for many many times
we still have faced with this question
and its most obvious if you look at the
international system which as we said
previously already this morning we all
talk many much about international I
mean it's probably a world many of you
use at least 10 or 20 times a day and
when you use this word international
what you have in mind is the Intel in
the International the reality is what we
all also have in mind
is that what we have in mind when we use
this word international is the world
national and this is what really matters
in other words when we say international
we say this is
between nations we reaffirm the reality
of the international system of today
which is that it is made of nations
which this old this valiant structure
which was born in 1648 the end of the
process which led to the Peace of
Westphalia and where international world
organization international systems are
the monopolies have now 200 sovereign
nation-states
who can all not decide to enter into
respective obligations and thus leading
to this well known problem of
international law which is you know
whether the international system is
about building a community or whether
it's about adjusting different
sovereignties and this of course relates
to schools of thought which have been
there for a long time on the community
side sort of cosmopolitan philosophy
which has been developed notably in
European philosophy in the 17th 18th
19th century or even in what appeared in
this social doctrine of the Catholic
Church at the end of the 19th century
with this notion of the necessity a
universal authority as they said or
whether it belongs to a more sort of
metal nation tradition sovereignty
articulation which remains in the facts
and in the fundamentals of international
public law
the dominant feature there was a
cosmopolitan there is a cosmopolitan
thinking in some people's mind the
reality if you practice international
law if you practice international
organization is that this is still
based on national sovereignty much more
than on any view that we are trying to
build a sort of a community hence hence
the International aspect of this tension
now how to address this issue very very
sketchy Lee I think there are various
ways to do this both by experience and
by observation the first one is the
classical one you recognize you assess
you start from the assumption that the
system is about 200 sovereigns trying to
work together to build rules where we
need rules in international governance
to create international organizations
the purpose of which is to administer
these rules and that's how most of the
international system was built since
roughly the 19th century leading to the
UN system to the Battenberg system after
what happened between the two world wars
this edification member-driven system of
organization were system of
organizations which are member driven
leading to let's say the last floor
which was built in this edifice in the
mid 90s the latest important
international organization being set up
being this International Criminal Court
now what we all know is that this the
stallion member driven bottom-up
edification from the agreement between
sovereigns is
less effective than what we wish it to
be and by the way roughly the move
edification the system of international
institutions has been stalling since the
mid 90s which is roughly 20 years ago
for a variety of reasons which I don't
have time to expand on but which have to
do with the growing number of sovereigns
in this planet and with the rebalancing
of political forces history having shown
that the ideological matrix of a system
was Western and creates problem if
countries with a non-western on
topological and political matrix have to
use it the other Avenue to try and fix
the discrepancy between global more
global issues and still local governance
is the sort of post Italian Supra
national Avenue which is where Europe
has engaged in in the 1950s which is
another way based on proximity regional
proximity to try and address these
issues and the European experience so
far has been in many ways extremely
successful in some areas but as we've
seen in recent times also prone to
difficulties especially in moments of
crisis where national systems national
thinking reappear on the surface
difficulty and economic and social
tensions so in many ways Europe or
regional integration and there are
regional integration process
elsewhere than in Europe whether you
look at Central America sub regions in
Africa as an 10 for instance although
nothing like the sort of very ambitious
step forward which the European
institutions created this Avenue is
there but we know it's also not the sort
of Royal Avenue that will solve the
tension the third way of trying to
address this is precisely what we say
discovered in this Oxford Martin School
Commission report where we tried to look
at how could we better address a number
of these global challenges not on
grounds of a philosophy but on grounds
of a thorough observation of what worked
and what did not work for the last
decades
why did hiv/aids work they'd say
reasonably well why did the ozone layer
issue work will be well what did y2k
work will be well and why did climate
change not work well but why does ocean
depletion not work well why did
financial regulation before the weight
crisis not work at all and stemming from
a pragmatic analytical approach why what
work work and why what didn't work
didn't work we outlined a number of
principles and then a number of
proposals on the mega trends and
challenges which we have identified
hence a number of proposals and those of
you who are interested could look at the
detailed nature of these 15 quite
innovative proposals but if I have to
choose one
sort of novelty in these proposals in
terms of how to address this tension
between global issues and local
governance one of the recipes is go the
way of trans stakeholders coalitions
what worked better than what what did
not work was when sovereigns or sub
sovereigns business organizations
notably multinational civil society
organizations coil eyes together
starting from a different purpose what
they were after they all have their own
way
looking at their interest when they
succeeded in quality and just to give
you one example
the stallion approach leads to the way
the UN Security Council is composed you
have nation-states who are sitting there
and you've got super few of them who are
super nation-states because they have a
veto right now on the Oxford mounting
side look at how the board of the Global
Fund on hiv/aids which is a very recent
creation is composed you have
representatives of sovereigns you have a
percentage of the pharmaceutical
industry you have representatives of
NGOs you have the representative number
of philanthropic institutions so it's
much more diverse composition clearly
not in line with the Westphalian
principle but the truth is that the
global found in many ways works a bit
better than units and UN aids was
created to work to be better than
the whu-oh which is stuck in many ways
like WTO like the FAO like many of these
organization which is stuck in getting a
consensus between 200 sovereigns so
those are various avenues which can be
considered before I conclude let me
mention two issues which I think are
ahead of us if we can as we should be
better at balancing this tension the
first one and that's proposal number 15
in the Oxford Martin report has to do
with values and we were discussing this
at lunch clearly whatever way you can
build to work around the best phalion
international system and there are ways
to do that which are innovative and
which need to be tested notably on
things like climate change there is one
issue which we will not escape which is
to try and build a sense of a global
community now of course it's terribly
difficult because as I said community is
local and it will take time before we
all sort of feel citizens of the world
with a sort of sense of belonging to
this planet which is same sort of our
feeling of belonging to a town of region
or a nation but we will not escape to
try and build more consensus on the
values which is different for instance
national communities have in common
the existence of a common glue cement
values being an important element of
national for instance identities now
addressing this will be necessary we
probably come from the world where we
could live with reasonably disconnected
value systems I think this time of human
history is over in the future we will
need to address these connections
because simply the evolution of market
capitalism of technology creates
connection that were not there before
and I know that having worked in the
field of international trade for let's
say 25 years of my life more or less
directly this notion that globalization
which has a lot to do with international
trade and investment as you were saying
in your introduction is there is clearly
going to increase and will raise
problems which we did not have before in
the old times of trade negotiations the
issue was to cope with trade obstacles
which the purpose of which was to
protect domestic producers from foreign
competition now in the new world of
trade obstacles they will have to cope
with issues which are not about
protecting producers and there are many
reasons why producers don't need to be
protected today the way they were
protected before but with issues that
stem from the different ways of
protecting the consumer in other words
moving from protection to precaution and
this raises
very different problems and create a
much more immediate necessity to
understand connect approximate sometimes
harmonized value systems and if you take
the example of this new big
transatlantic negotiation that started
last year most of what you have to do if
you want to open trade transatlantic has
to do with addressing regulatory
differences not tariff differences it's
the case if you look at car safety for
instance the u.s. standard what a safe
car is and the EU standard what a safe
car is are quite different which of
course is a problem if I'm the if I'm in
the business of producing cars I'm sure
I'll produce cars cheaper if I the same
standard on these two big deep markets
now how far do we need to go in this
approximation values is an open question
we probably do not need that if it's
about whether death penalty is right or
wrong we don't need to approximate this
we probably can live on the planet where
there are huge value differences of this
kind but we probably cannot live on a
planet where what routes the concept of
privacy for instance data privacy these
will need to be addressed because if we
don't have the same concept at some
stage of what data privacy means then
the efficiencies of the global systems
will not accrue and this leads me to
this conclusion which is that looking at
very respected and global university
like this one there is probably be
contribution to make for academics to
moving this reflection forward I'm just
mentioning to what could be inputted in
such sort forward-looking you I recently
reread Marshall Sahlins book about the
generation of Western thought and I
thought what he called the Western
illusion of human nature looking at this
issue how to address value-based
differences in through the lens of
anthropology technology of sociology I
think would bring a lot to this
discussion as well as we're looking for
instance at what
Palani wrote at the time where he was
considering how economic systems and
social systems could become these
embedded well we are moving to a world
where we will need to embed more and
more economic and social systems and I
think in this area human science social
sciences have a much larger contribution
to make than has been the case in the
past and my wish is that institutions
like yours with their strong
interdisciplinary capacity contribute to
that and if there's anything I can do to
move this in this direction I'll do it
gladly
thanks for your attention
well it's it's an honor to have been
asked to respond to the second annual
global thought lecture by Pascal Lamy
and and in particular to have a chance
to speak a bit about the report now for
the long term by the Oxford Martin
Commission for future generations
chaired by Pascal Lamy and a particular
pleasure to hear you refer to Marshall
Sahlins at the close of your of your
talk the the concerns raised by the work
of the Commission intersect with the
concerns of the Committee on global
thought here at Columbia University
above all else what Pascal Lamy means
lecture does building on the
commission's report is to explore the
challenges that will be faced by future
generations drawing on already available
scientific evidence and shifting the
focus of attention in order to convince
us that it is now that we need to start
addressing more seriously the most
fundamental long-term issues confronting
the planet ranging from the environment
to social inequalities to geopolitical
tensions the Commission has conducted a
systematic review of what has worked
previously and perhaps most importantly
what is not trying to understand the
reasons for both success and failure
with a keen eye for the complexity and
interconnectedness of these processes
and outcomes and based on this review
has sought to articulate a set of
principles and proposals that advance
the interests of future generations and
promote resilience inclusiveness and
sustainability the report is divided
into three parts the the first is about
the identification of what the
commissioner saw is the main megatrends
and challenges currently facing humanity
the second highlights what is known from
recent past about responses to these
megatrends and challenges seeking to
draw lessons from previous successes as
well as from past failures and in the
third part of the report the Commission
articulates a number of key principles
for action and provides recommendations
to help policymakers business leaders
and other decision-makers
overcome governance gridlock to adapt to
today's hyper-connected world to promote
openness and accountability to build
public trust and to focus on the
long-term needs of our global society as
examples
they've given us 15 specific proposals
aimed at creating new coalition's
multi-stakeholder partnerships and
reinvigorated institutions more suited
to 21st century challenges proposals
that revalue the future by investing in
future generations and in youth today
and that establish a common platform of
understanding a shared global vision in
order to build a new foundation for
shared global values while the
theoretical underpinnings of this work
are appropriately discreet in the
context of this lecture on global
thought it's worth briefly mentioning
something about its intellectual
architecture by focusing on the cluster
of keywords that link resilience
inclusiveness and sustainability the
analysis suggests critical
interconnections between ecology society
and subjectivity the richness of these
ideas is reflected in the many valence
electrons take as an example resilience
which features centrally in the work in
work on ecology in the literature on
responses to disaster in developmental
psychology and in the study of social
and political adaptation and
transformation in the study of ecology
for example resilience is typically
understood as the property of a system
that allows it to recover its prior
state after suffering a shock but
ecologists also see resilience in more
dynamic terms as adaptation or
transformation rather than simply as a
return to an earlier state as the
capacity of a system to absorb
disturbance to strengthen and
reorganizing while undergoing change to
recombine evolving structure
and processes not only renewing the
system but also allowing for the
emergence of new directions resilience
thus provides adaptive capacity in
developmental psychology resilience
typically describes a satisfactory
outcome after an individual has been
exposed to something that puts this at
risk like the loss of a loved one or the
experience of social depredation or
poverty resilience in overcoming such
challenges is linked to the availability
of social support as well as to concepts
of self-efficacy and empowerment
more recently in seeking to understand
the potential for patas positive
adaptations of communities and whole
societies to the all-too-often
destabilizing effects caused by
processes of globalization and
neoliberal social and economic policies
social scientists have sought to
understand social resilience as an
outcome in which groups of people
organizations communities classes racial
or ethnic groups countries or even
diasporas sustain or reconstruct
collective well-being physical or
psychological health sustainable
material conditions and sustenance and a
sense of basic human dignity in the face
of profound challenges here too
resilience is understood in dynamic
terms not simply as the capacity to
return to a pre-existing state but
rather as an achievement of well-being
and strength that may very well entail
significant changes in social practices
as well as changes to the kinds of
social and cultural frameworks that
organize and give meaning to these
practices social resilience enables
groups to achieve positive material as
well as symbolic outcomes under new or
changing circumstances understanding
resilience along these lines as
simultaneously ecological and social
individual and collective can thus link
back to inclusiveness and sustainability
enabling us to build a more inclusive
and sustainable foundation for
on the part of future generations yet of
resilience inclusiveness and
sustainability provide a particularly
useful underpinning and set of goals for
the Commission's analysis a number of
other clusters of keywords emerge that
perhaps require further thought there at
least two that I would like to highlight
in the time that I have available first
a cluster that takes shape around key
notions of governance and responsibility
and in particular in relation to
institutional change political
engagement and political processes and
second a cluster that takes shape more
around what I think we might describe as
symbolic processes and social
imaginaries in particular as they relate
to cultures values and voices although
one of the strongest aspects of the
Commission's work has been its attention
to the long term there are moments when
greater attention to the historical
complexity of political processes an
institutional change might offer further
insight and perhaps nowhere in the
commission's report was this more
evident to me than in the discussion of
the case that I know best after nearly
35 years of working on these issues the
relative success that best scholars has
mentioned in his talk this evening of
the global response to HIV and AIDS and
while the Commission is correct in
suggesting that the so-called scale-up
of HIV treatment programs in the mid
2000s was a crucial step forward in the
response to the pandemic and that a
partnership or perhaps more accurately a
division of labor between agencies such
as the World Bank the Global Fund the
u.s. PEPFAR program UN AIDS
w-h-o the Gates Foundation made an
important contribution to this process
it's important to emphasize that the
takeaway message should not be that this
was the result of of inspired leadership
whether at the national or international
levels the the progression that Pascal
described from WH o to un aid to the
Global Fund I think is especially
instructive this was part of a much more
complex long-term process of change that
deserves to be underlined
what a truly long-term view of the
history of the response to HIV most
clearly demonstrates is perhaps the
failure of leadership at almost every
level at least in the first instance
during the first decade of the epidemic
political leaders around the world not
only failed to address the emerging
epidemic but even to utter its name
international agencies first fled from
taking any responsibility and then later
spent most of their energy battling over
resources and conflicting philosophical
approaches when money finally began to
trickle toward the epidemic the
governments of most powerful northern
donors spent more time attending to the
interests of big pharma than to those of
their own citizens or the largely
stigmatized communities and populations
thought to be most vulnerable to HIV
infection in countries around the world
for at least two decades it was only
because of the stubborn resistance of
grassroots activists and a ragtag
collection of those generally perceived
to be social misfits together with their
strategic allies in diverse settings
practicing what might almost be
described as subversive resistance that
continued to move the fight against the
academic epidemic forward it was largely
thanks to the dogged persistence of men
and women still carrying the standard of
the sanitary reform movement and willing
to challenge the convictions of World
Bank economists that gradually led to a
perception of the mistaken notion that
only primary prevention could be cost
effective and to the conditions that
began to be created for the success of
treatment scale-up in the 2000s in short
what the case of HIV illustrates when
analyzed from a long-term perspective is
just how truly complex political
processes political engagement and
institutional change are and the pivotal
role not only of world leaders and
global institutions but also of
grassroots activists emerging social
movements and outraged citizens before a
partnership of intergovernmental
organizations or donor agencies
committed to HIV treatment access could
even be imagined
and we had to win the moral battle over
why every life must matter even after we
reached the tipping point in this debate
the irony was that many of the very
agencies such as our own governments
PEPFAR program responsible for
implementing treatment access
simultaneously imposed moralistic
restrictions on access to prevention
such as abstinence only sexuality
education programs and restrictions on
the rights of affected communities and
the reality today with significant
long-term consequences is that for every
two people who successfully managed to
access HIV treatment five more are newly
infected with HIV obviously the Oxford
Martin commissioners including my own
colleague and friend of many years
professor Peter Piot are well aware of
these complexities and contradictions
but the key point extends beyond the
specifics of the global response to HIV
with its mixture of success and failure
perhaps it's about the importance of
building a more complex understanding of
political processes in the 21st century
and the ways in which this complexity
may open up possibilities for change in
institutions policies and the politics
of daily life this brings me to one last
point perhaps most clearly evident in
the third cluster of key terms that
operate throughout the commission's
report and that Pascal Lamy mentioned in
his comments this evening cultures
values and voices culture seems to play
an especially contradictory role on the
one hand cultural biases are seen as
fundamental barriers to change that shut
many women and young people out of
critical conversations and enquiries
transforming culturally determined and
articulated values may be essential then
to reorient in our focus toward a
long-term future to bring new voices
into the global conversation to create
from the diversity of histories and
perspectives a new set of common values
capable of binding the members of the
international system together
but if cultural biases can be seen as
posing barriers to change it is also
true
the cultural meanings are essential to
the interconnectedness that is stressed
throughout the commission's report
societies are bound together not only
through the ties of social relationships
but also through collective imaginaries
by narratives about the past and about
the future about the social
organisations that we live in and about
the political struggles that we engage
in collective imaginaries can be the
source of resilience and of a society's
ability to change yet as the commission
clearly emphasizes they can also be a
central justification for discrimination
and exclusion again it is here in
relation to the issues of discrimination
and conclude exclusion that I feel the
need for greater detail and clarity
while the commission's report
consistently emphasizes
interconnectedness the more nuanced ways
in which exclusion operates receive
relatively less attention race for
example is hardly mentioned and racism
is never mentioned at all racial and
ethnic discrimination are mentioned only
once gender and gender inequality are
mentioned yet a more nuanced
understanding of the ways in which
gender power operates through cultural
narratives and values is largely absent
here I suppose it still needs to be
emphasized that women and gender are not
one in the same thing it is important to
stress that the point here is not to
demand that a commission report should
be transformed into a sociological
treatise an expectation that would be
both unfair and unrealistic but I do
want to emphasize the importance of
seeking to balance the Commission's
concern with interconnectedness with an
equally important need to address
intersectionality the intersection of
multiple forms of inequality and the
synergy between multiple forms of
structural violence that coexist and
interact in such complex ways in the
contemporary world we need to focus not
only on these broad forms of exclusion
but on the ways in which racial and
ethnic discrimination gender power
inequalities sexual oppressions in short
multiple and multiplex forms of stigma
and just
rumination based on social and cultural
difference operate in contemporary
societies if we were to think
realistically about the long-term goals
of resilience inclusion and
sustainability Pascal Lamy and the
Oxford Martin Commission are clearly
correct in emphasizing the need for a
common set of values capable of opening
up new social and cultural spaces
necessary to hear the voices that have
too often been silenced and excluded in
the past it is only through dialogue
dialogue that seeks to progressively
broaden the range of voices that are
engaged that the possibilities of our
long-term future can be constructed this
understanding lies at the heart of all
the most important lessons from the
Commission's work it is precisely by
building up a diverse interdisciplinary
dialogue about the future and its
challenges articulated within a global
perspective that the Commission has been
able to address the key problems that
will determine the lives and
possibilities of future generations that
is what motivates the Committee on
global thought at Columbia University as
well the spirit of dialogue and
interdisciplinarity beyond our immediate
concerns and networks and of training
and mentoring new generations to address
a global future this too is precisely
the spirit of this annual global thought
lecture and it is why Pascal Lamy was
such an exceptional choice to deliver
the second annual lecture and why we
thank him deeply for sharing his
thoughts with us today just as we thank
all of you for being here with us thank
you
let me start by by saying how much I
appreciate this opportunity now to
moderate the discussion I also had the I
was also commissioned by the committee
Lowell thought to invite for this
lecture Pascal Lamy which was of course
an honor having had the opportunity to
interact with him during the years we
happen to be together in the chief
executive board the United Nations
system with one peculiarity which I
never understood which is why WTO is not
a UN organization which is of course by
itself an interesting historical
question in any case a linear the mr.
perhaps by asking him to what you know
to react to professors Parker's coming
and perhaps say I'll continue with maybe
one or a couple of questions and open
the floor for where it was to to ask
questions yeah I mean three short
reactions first on the nature of
globalization and its political analysis
and position the members of the
Commission which were coming from very
different right hands both
intellectually politically nationally I
think the consensus was that it has both
huge opportunities and huge risks that
was the sort of ideological pace I don't
think anybody around this table would
the sort of French view that
liberalization is terrible and nothing
else nor would anybody take the view by
some that this is a new paradise
so it's it's the result of forces some
of which are structure earlier and which
humans can you do it with currents waves
or winds use in the right direction or
in the wrong direction on the complexity
of political processes and I very much
appreciated what you said on the way
hiv/aids started from this total lack of
sense and leadership and through a messy
process where activists including
grassroots activists which were using
methods I would not recommend to use in
public life but if I look at history I
mean in a way did their job is this this
the way you cross the river from
knowledge to action which is one of the
lessons the Oxford Martin report which
is that in order to do that you have to
build the bridge with several arches so
you start from knowledge and then you
have to build an arch which needs from
knowledge to awareness and moving from
knowledge to awareness is in itself a
complex process that mobilizes social
forces
a specific nature and then you have to
move from awareness to mobilization
which again is a different game which
mobilizes different actors and different
political processes and then you have to
move from mobilization to action and
this is much more with what we commonly
understand as the world of politics and
only then you reach the other side of
the river and if you take the various
examples which we analyze that works and
the inward I am now part of a global
Commission illusions which will report
by the mid June here in New York or in
Washington which is a big global
Commission which in a way is a parent of
this absurd Martin Commission which is
focused on why do we mistreat options
the way we do it whereas we know by
science the huge cost of humanity what
we are doing which is basically putting
too many things in oceans and taking too
many things from oceans so this this
complexity of political processes I
think you're absolutely right
is but anyway you can try and simplify
it if if you take one of these issues
and you try to move it and last last
remark about what you said on cultural
differences which is in many ways a
parallel to what I said on on governance
and proximity one could see the problem
of governance being local as a
constraint as a problem like one could
see cultural differences as an obstacle
to but then no you have to go back to
basics
and I mean there's there's nothing like
a permanent contradiction and one of the
terms has to overcome the other and I
personally believe that cultural
diversity is as essential as Garrett not
least because it has a lot to do with
the identity now how do you cope with
that I think you have to start from the
affirmation of a political principle
that cultural diversity has to do with
identity and that identity is a
fundamental principle of human dignity
now if you start from there then you can
move to this consideration that in
reality and we were discussing this at
last time in reality it's not so much
cultural differences which are an
obstacle to a common approach
it's the ignorant of these differences
that is the real problem and the
experience shows that once you've
overcome this ignorance ie once you
understand what your interlocutor has in
mind because of a cultural diversity
then a common solution is possible and I
had I mean we're in public so I can't go
too much into detail but I had a problem
like this we had a problem like this
which finally did not surface and just
an example of these differences and the
way to cope with them at some stage in
recent years Australian animal welfare
activists put a big pressure on the
Australian government to stop exporting
beef to Indonesia because Hal are
slaughtering cows in Indonesia seen by
these activists as a huge problem now
typical case of cultural differences I
mean these animal welfare activists in
Australia or sincerely
so concerned that these poor cows should
not suffer but you know the guys that
administer allows fluttering in
Indonesia which is a reasonably stable
and moderate Muslim country don't see
this way so and there is no way you can
address this problem and saying one is
right and the other is wrong but the
simple fact that they they had this
dialogue and they started understanding
their point of view led to well we're
not going to create a big possibility so
the cultural difference remains but the
knowledge of why it's done the other way
by somebody different so and and I think
there is a huge pit progress that can be
made in many places on this on this on
this planet which so far is not explored
and sometimes leads to these frictions
which can become tensions which can
become complex okay thank you for those
of you want to to ask questions there
are two microphones on each side in any
child so they let me say that after this
question we'll open the floor for the so
my my question is the following I mean
you were talk you mentioned this tension
between the global nature of the
problems that you raised in the report
in particularly the mega trends and the
delivery of governance which is
associated with the closeness to the
citizens the same now a digit rate of
course two to one point in the diagnosis
of of the report which I found of course
having worked for internationalization
quite shocking which is that the
institution's bill for the 20th century
they have a legitimacy Authority and
effectiveness deficits
which is a quite a strong statement now
local governance cannot respond to
global issues on the other hand you know
it has to be in a sense global
institutions so my question is is there
any hope of these global institutions
playing the role well what you said just
now is what I was thinking 10 years ago
when I wrote a small book about global
governance about global democracy
starting from your premise that local
governance cannot address local problems
and that you need global governance with
rescue other problems
and to be frank eff I've changed my mind
of this not that we do not need a global
governance approach to global problems
but we cannot put all our eggs in this
basket and we need to keep a lot of our
eggs in the local basket because this is
what works so in many ways you know I
started at the time and at the time I
was I was working for the European Union
so my view of global governance was
still a bit idealistic after 10 years in
WTO I can tell you I have been grounded
to more realities next book I have in
mind but not before 10 years because I I
don't intend to
totally retire and I have to do that
when I have written this book is about
diplomacy which is about how diplomat
from the international system but that's
that's for the future now to answer your
question I think the solution is not so
much in globalizing local
problems than in localizing global
problems and I think political processes
should be thought and neared in such a
way that you create the necessary
political pressure at the level sort of
if not grassroots at least a part of
them and no going back to this
fascinating example in many ways
hiv/aids which still is a big problem
that's also one of the lessons and
experience so I think global
organizations have intrinsic problems
which won't be easy to solve
whether it's UN whether it's Bretton
Woods with Aris WTO there are many
reasons why this system is focused
ination problem at least not least
because the security of the system is
that it's in the hands of the class of
diplomats who's sort of basic purpose is
to remain in the position they have when
they are posted abroad so I mean a good
sociological approach to this would lead
to the conclusion that the actors of the
system don't have that big incentive for
the system to find solutions there
they're not needed anymore
so there are fundamental reasons of the
way the system works I think they can be
improved and by the way we make a
reasonably public active proposal in
this report that each international
organization should have a review clause
and that every tenure is purpose mandate
members engagement should be we
discussed if not we negotiate but I mean
we even discussed there was not no
consensus we even discussed a tougher
version which was a sunset clause that
international organization should be set
up for 10 years or 20 years and then and
then if you really need them you
recreate them from a fresh mandate but
there are insurance equations why these
systems lack efficiency are told to be
ocassi and you know if if if the proper
definition of a bureaucracy is an
organization that uses more than 50% of
its resources to transact with itself
many international organizations are at
the level of 75 mm of transaction with
themselves which clearly is a problem so
progress can be made we need global
institution we need them to work better
but I don't think we should again we
should keep a lot of our eggs in making
global issues more local through
increasing local governments
accountability on global issues urban
studies student here at Columbia
University
I'm throughout the day I was with you
earlier this morning as well you spoke
even speaking a lot about you know these
rise of supranational institutions like
the EU where you've worked on as well as
you know this focus back to back down to
the local really by putting more like
you said more of the eggs back down to
the local level
I was wondering from your experience
working across all these different
levels of government do you still see a
place or the for the nation-state like
how will that change if there's even a
place for it at all I'm sorry of course
there is a place for the nation-state
and there is a place for the
nation-state
not because
not because of the principles of the
peace of westphalia or not because of
the theory of international law and I'm
more on the communitarian side then on
the sovereign side but there is a place
for the nation state because the nation
state remains a level of identity
belonging together nets
hence legitimacy and if with my own
concept of how political power must work
I give a premium to a parameter which
has a strong sense of belonging because
this is the justification of political
power now we may we may think that
nations are sort of remin remnant of the
past which by the way is not true
historically the world has lived without
nations for a very long period of its
history in many ways it's a relatively
recent creation of a specific level of
legitimacy but I think as long as
nations for reasons which we can discuss
whether nations have their have their so
to own historical legitimacy and notably
the way I'm French so I know what
building Nations means in terms of
torturing people killing people and
making sure you know this little king of
a little bit of the part of this
territory made sure that through armed
forces and conflicts and wars including
was religion the thing got together and
I and I know the difference between this
historical reality and the mythology
which I learned in my history both
that was sorta bunch of heroes which
constructed this country with their
great heart and their big river but the
reality is that in public perceptions it
is a level of political legitimacy
it might change but it will only change
if the sense of belonging and
togetherness of people change and this
is a very very long process and the
experience in the Opera Union showed up
although these countries have a lot in
common
for instance in terms of values I mean
if you analyze the 28 members of the
plan Union and you could add to that
Switzerland or no way because the fact
that they are not a member of the Union
is is in history accident but if you
look at what they have in common they
have a lot in common in values and yet
and yet there are still areas or
elements where the legitimacy of a
supranational space and we'll see that
in the next European elections it's
probable that the level of participation
in the European elections which is
roughly 40 percent less than national
elections and national elections by the
way are usually less participation than
local elections says I think a lot on
this hierarchy legitimacy I must say
that in many countries local versus
national it's actually the opposite yeah
in America generally the participation
national elections is higher than in
local yeah yes go ahead yes thank you
I'm Janet Gerson from the global
community forum and my colleagues and I
are especially interested with these
concepts and principles of how to
connect with global community how to
bring the local into the
the global into the local that's a great
beginning to this disconnect that were
concerned with and were particularly
interested in issues that you would
think would be useful for research with
psychology and education I mean I as I
said in the finite part of this short
remarks I think the contribution human
and social sciences to these
problematics
is totally under use if I compare the
input of economists lawyers political
scientists into this let's say global
governance science if if it deserves
this name - what on topology is it
knowledge psychology social mean this
proportion is is enormous so I think
there is a lot to be done in this
direction including by the way in
looking at what you mentioned when you
talked about symbolic imagination and
cultural elements and of course
education plays a huge role in that
we've all been brainwashed by our
teachers when we were 5 6 7 10 15 years
old in the way we've been taught history
so this this this is this is a necessity
but on the other side we again we should
not we shouldn't over use the notion
that there is something like a global
community as long as there is not a
global
and how many times and you you've lived
longer than I have in the in the UN
system how many times did we hear the
international community thinks that all
the international community should all
the international community did not
behave what is the international
community is there anything like its its
semantics the desire is the semantics of
a dream and find ways desire and dream
it's great thing in life but we
shouldn't take this for reality and we
sometimes have a salt you know capacity
to to hide big difference or big
disagreements in sort of formulations
like this which I think are misleading
and sometimes can lead to you know
saying saying this this bloodbath in
Syria is because the international
community behavior doesn't lead in my
view anywhere in terms of operational
consequences we have to look at why it
happens and how it happens and what can
be done to limit sort of massacres of
this time but I don't think saying
that's about the international community
will help a lot let's take this last
question hi my name is John a student
here at Business School my question is I
mean can you talk about other like this
awareness and this Vonage especially the
dis manage for countries to join the
international organization like WTO
thank you
in terms of accession and joining WTO
the system is purely the salient WTO
agreements are treaties that members of
the media have ratified so they are
bound by network disciplines which they
have jointly agreed to abide and joining
the organization is about accepting the
common rule of the club so the club has
its rules and if you accept the rules of
the kaabah then you're admitted as a
member of the club plus the fact that
you have to pay your your membership
because admitting the rules of the club
is only credible in terms of
international trade opening if you pay
your membership fee in opening our
economy now this is the technical part
of the item and which is why 160 members
and that only limited number members the
quote unquote international community
let's say UN General Assembly to be more
precise legally are not are not members
but it's now ninety percent ninety three
or four percent world trade now the
reason why let's say let's take two
different cases and I hope I'm not
breaching any any logical rule
why is Algeria not a member of W
because Egeria has problems in
understanding what WTO is about under
members have a problem in understanding
what algeria is about so it's a
classical sort of misunderstanding issue
and it will take time before the
political leaders lend to international
trade the same sort of benefit as the
average WTO member so classical simple
thing
why is Iran not a WTO member because in
order for countries to become the video
there is a process that at some stage
says you create a committee which will
examine the terms of the negotiation
accession we view the commitment and in
order for this committee to be created a
chair of the committee has to be
nominated and it just happened that in
the case of Iran no chair of the
committee was agreed by the members
simply because US and EU and a few
others said we don't want to agree on
nominating a chair of the committee
which is a purely political issue but
which of course is framed as a
procedural issue
like many purely political issues in
international life so this is in this
case it's a purely political reason that
explains why the negotiations are not
going anywhere
whereas in the case of Algeria it's more
of a normalization system but in theory
any country can ask to join and again it
will join if the consensus along 160
members is that this new member can be
accepted well let me say Pascal how
deeply honor we feel
in the committee level thought for you
having accepted to give deliver this
second annual lecture and let me say
also in behalf of the Columbia community
that we have also been honored normally
by lecture but also the time you spend
with the students and professors during
this day thank you very much
you